You can build gorgeous websites with
Claude Code and Nano Banana 2, even if
you're starting with zero experience.
But 99% of people don't know how to
build profitable websites. Which is why
in this video, I'm going to show you
exactly how to build animated websites
that people pay thousands of dollars
for. I'm new website intelligence system
that turns viewers into buyers. And if
you don't know who I am, my name is Jack
Roberts. I built and sold my last tech
[music] startup. There was 60,000
customers. And I've sold websites like
these for thousands of dollars. And this
is all I do all day, every day. So,
[music] if you haven't already, grab
that coffee and let's dive straight in.
Gorgeous websites can sell for thousands
of dollars using Claude Code and the new
Nano Banana 2. Stuff that wasn't really
possible previously, and I'm going to
show you exactly how to do it in this
video, but you also need intelligence.
Now, what kind of intelligence? Well, we
need intelligence about the niche that
the website sits in. We need to be able
to analyze what the best performing
businesses in that niche are actually
doing. We need a website that actually
supports our core offer, whatever that
might be. A law firm versus a HVAC
company. Completely different business
model. And we can do all of this using
fire crawl intelligence. Super exciting
technology. And basically, I'm also
going to show you in this video as well
how you can set up a system to enable
your client to request changes to that
very specific website and how you might
want to handle that if you're selling
it. So by using cloud code nanob banana
and firecrawl we can do five things. I'm
going to show you exactly how you can
scrape a logo from any website. How you
can get the copy from that website. How
you can get intelligence on competitors
and the top performers in any niche on
the planet systematically. How you can
then actually create a 3D animated hero
asset that makes your website stand out
and how we can go ahead and create
something that is pretty exceptional.
And to do this there's only three things
that we need to do. Step one is going to
be gathering intelligence on the website
and the niche so that we can actually
find out what best-in-class looks like,
then build our beautiful website all
around that. Now, to do this, we need to
pick a niche. I suggest for this one
that we go ahead and we do something
along the lines of pool cleaners in
Texas. So, let's say for example, we
work with a company in pool cleaners in
Texas or we wanted to work with these
companies directly. What we're going to
do is find a random website. I find one
here that we're going to use, which is
diamondpools.com. So we use this as an
example to see how we can take that
website into stellar. This is uh what it
looks like. Cool. So now the first thing
we need to do is basically open up clo
code which we're going to use in
anti-gravity. And then we're going to
bring a prepackaged skill that I
designed for you. So you can just
literally download it. All the resources
are completely free for you. Just click
the links in description down below. So
I'm going to download anti-gravity. That
sounds like Spanish. Check out the video
on screen. Runs through everything that
you need to know. So with an
anti-gravity, it's basically software
that just builds software. Going to
click on file on the top left. Come down
to open folder. Come down here. Click on
new folder and we'll call this one pool
cleaner. Awesome. Then click on create
and then click on open. Now we're in the
pool cleaner folder. Yes, we trust the
authors. Now we want to leverage cla
code. So to do that on the left hand
side and if you haven't already, you can
just download codes. You can access it
with an anti-gravity. Once that happens,
you'll see this thing appear on the
left. You can just click on that and
have a full conversation with it by
clicking on new session. Cool.
Alternatively, if you want, you can just
double click in the middle and then
click on the orange thing at the top.
Now, what we're going to do is download
a skill that I've already pre-built for
you. And then we're going to connect
that to firecrawl, which is this
beautiful website here, which is going
to go out and find literally the top
performing pool cleaning websites that
exist in that area. It's going to find
out what do they have in common, what
features do they have, what product is
our website trying to sell, and use all
of that to build us the blueprint for a
really incredible website. And then
we're going to build something
incredibly animated on top of it. So,
let's go ahead and grab the resources.
And again, I'll pop this all for you
down below in description so you can
just grab it. Let's come over to the
vault and grab this one here. So, we're
looking for this one here, which is
awesome. And I want you to do is come
and click on website builder system.
Obviously, it'll be slightly different
for you when you click on it. Great. And
then what I want you to do is come over
here to website builder. Click on this
and literally just download the entire
file together. And it'll download it as
a zip. You're going to open up your
downloads. Just double click on this guy
like so. And now we got the website
builder. Then anti-gravity. Just click
these to get to the document area. Come
back to downloads and just drag this guy
over to the left hand side and click on
add folder to workspace. And then we're
going to give Claude the following
prompt. Hey there. I'd like you to
familiarize yourself with the website
builder skill on the left hand side. I
want you to repeat back to me everything
you're going to do step by step. Once
you've done that, I want you to turn
that into a skill that you yourself are
going to save so I can use it whenever I
want to in the future. And if you ever
find that this Claude code is
misbehaving, you can also click on the
terminal up top, click on new terminal,
open up, click enter, and then
essentially down here, what you can do
is just simply come down, bring this up,
type in the word claude, and then you
can do the exact same prompt here. It's
just in case you ever run into any
issues within the actual interface. And
since this one is struggling a little
bit, what I'm going to do is close this
one down and we're going to use this one
here. We're going to right click and
click on panel position and just put
this on the right hand side. I always
like to keep these things in so you get
a fully 100% realistic experience of
building everything and that you can
crush it. So within Claude Code, there's
only three things that we're going to
do. It's going to be a process. It's
going to suit the market, learn from
winners, and build a website grounded in
intelligence. First of all is to gather
and understand. We're going to scrape
the entire website that we give it with
the fire crawl API. We're going to build
a full picture of the business and then
we're going to audit the current
messaging, the strengths, the gaps so we
know what the starting position is.
Again, it isn't just a gorgeous website.
It's got substance. Then we're going to
do competitive research. We're going to
find the top five competitors ranked by
Google reviews, Trust Pilot, and search
visibility. We're going to scrub each
competitor, their design, content,
branding, logos, and SEO. We're going to
synthesize what all the five winners
have in common and the blueprint of what
actually works in your market. Then
finally, we're going to have a beautiful
print ready report with competitor
profiles, logos, and brand colors side
by side, SEO, landscape, keyword gaps,
and a polished deliverable that we can
actually also give to the client. And in
addition to the website or for your own
benefit, so you get a real sense of what
everything exists in your own market.
And then what we're going to say to code
is, look, I want you to turn this into a
claw code skill. And once you've done
that, you can do for slash and then you
can come down and do website builder
like so. Hit enter and then we can bin
the entire process. Now, the first thing
we're going to need is a fire crawl API.
So let's come ahead and go ahead and
grab this from Fiverr. You can get
started with it completely for free. So
let's head over to the dashboard. And
literally on the homepage itself, you
can see the API key. So we're going to
grab this right here. We're going to
skip this for now and then head that
give it basically back over to claude
code. And then in claude code, we're
going to give it two things. One is
going to be the fire crawl API key. And
then we're also going to give it the
website URL, which for us is going to be
diamondpools.com. We head back over and
give that to Claude, guys. And just like
that, it's come back and processed
everything without touching a single
thing. And what it's done is given us a
Diamond D pool services market
intelligence report. So this is an asset
that we could give to clients or just
good for us for them individually. You
know what I mean? Oh my goodness. I'm
I'm excited to dive into this. So a
research driven analysis of the East
Texas pool service market competitive
profile success patterns and strategic
recommendations for building a website
that wins. Cool executive summary. I
love the premium feel that we've got
with us. I think it's fantastic. So what
do we learn here? So you're in a
competitive East Texas pool service
market. Here are the specific niches.
Trust signals are table stakes,
professional photography wins, content
depth drives SEO. The top five all
showcase real completed project photos,
name designs, galleries, before and
after shots, stock imagery signals,
small operation. How cool is that? By
the way, that you just get to share this
insight. And I get people reaching out
to me very often with, "Jack, I did a
full deep dive analysis on your
business. Here's what you're missing. It
doesn't look like this. I can tell you
that for a fact. It's very obviously AI
generated. This looks like it's had some
car and attention. You know, I challenge
you to tell me the last time you had
something that looked this good that
came for free. Content depth for SEO
winners have service pages, FAQ section,
blog content. Really cool, really
helpful insights. Current website audit.
So, we come down here. Strength trust
sets us apart and critical gaps.
Interesting. Duplicate H4 headings. It's
done a full SEO review, Gmail contact
address. Interesting. Come down here.
Bottom line, the current site
communicates part-time side gig rather
than professional pool service company.
Then we got competitor profiles. And
again, it's got all this key information
here, which is cool. It's got all their
trust pilot reviews. And guys, look at
this. We've even got their color
palettes. How freaking amazing is that?
Then we can zoom out a little bit and
have a quick look over here. Let me just
zoom out so you can see what they do
exceptionally well. Paradise nails a
personal touch. Own a bios named Paul
Designs. Here's another one. Here's
their reviews. And here's what they do.
Well, this is amazing. I am genuinely
impressed by this. Genuinely, genuinely
impressed by this. I think this is
fantastic. This is really gorgeous.
Again, I'll add this to the skill for
you so that you're going to get the same
thing. If you want to share this with
clients to grow your base or whatever,
or just want to look at it for yourself,
you can do it. really freaking cool what
they do exception well. We come down and
we get an idea for the color palette of
everything. And then we got at the
bottom the winning blueprint page
structure is hero strong headline
service categories photo gallery about
us content patterns and now we can use
what actually wins. And here's the crazy
thing. This has a really intelligent
algorithm about how it determines what
the top websites are. We do that based
on Google rankings. We do that based on
the reviews. So we get and and several
other factors that are inside the actual
skill. but it will identify what the top
players are and then we can reverse
engineer what makes them so great on
their website which I think is really
freaking cool. Then we got the SEO
landscape. Look at this guys. Here's
what they all do. Here's what you do.
This is like the kind of thing you'd
expect offer paid off a paid order. I'm
really impressed with this. Recommended
website structure home services about
blah blah blah blah. And then imagine
sending this and be like and by the way
here you freaking go it's yours is
amazing proposed design structure
fantastic absolutely gorgeous. And
that's basically the whole plan of
action. Then if we come back over to our
wonderful CL code, it is now ready to go
ahead and build it. So it's even got an
SEO plan, trust signals, content
strategy, page structure, which is
awesome. So now we're going tohead go
ahead and do it. And once we've done
that, we can then integrate our 3D
animated section. Hey there dude, that
sounds great. Go ahead and build that
initial website. Making sure that we
leave a space for me to give you the
video to do the integrated animated
structure uh for the pool. And then we
send them off. And if you're wondering
how I'm doing this, I'm using Glido as a
speechto text service. Basically, you
hit a key, yap, and then the messages
appear. Just saves a lot of time.
Wonderful. Course now we've got our
website SEO optimize and influence. So
we've got the homepage of where we're
going to have our beautiful animation.
Let's scroll down and see what we've
got. Gorgeous images, free estimates,
fivestar service. This really feels like
a premium brand. Cool pool care that
protects your investment. Some great
imagery there. Okay, this is quite
tasty. Your neighbor, your pool guy.
This is cool. Pools are transformed. Got
some different ideas and um proof there.
Six reasons to trust us. Okay, so this
is something that we want to kind of fix
this kind of like gradient thing, but
completely fine. First draft that's
fine. Come down. Proed by Paul earners.
This, by the way, pulls it directly from
the website. So, these should be actual
reviews that exist on Google, which is
fantastic. Come down. Your pool deserves
better. Let's make it happen. Proudly
serving East Texas. Lots of different
brands there. And then ready for a pool
cleaner. And then we've got a nice uh
contact form at the bottom where they
can get started. So, now we have a
initial overview of the website. The
next step is to take this interstellar
by bringing a beautiful showstoppping
animation that we can add directly into
the website with Nano Banana 2. Now, to
do this, I'm heading back over to
Community Grab 2 assets. I'll put these
down below so you can grab these
particular ones. We're going to look for
the 3D website builder and then we're
also looking for asset generation and of
course your SEO optimizer. Little side
note by the way, you do want to be
building out your skills repository of
Claude Skills. It's going to set you up
whether you're using Open Claw or just
building out systems. So, two things we
want to download. Number one is 3D
website builder. So, come down here and
just click on download this one real
quick. And then we're going to go ahead
and download the second. And then we've
got our asset generator. And let's just
download this one. So once we've
downloaded them guys, we're going to
select both of these and we're going to
drag them over to our folder. Yes, add
folders to workspace. Beautiful. And we
open a brand new thing. If you're using
a terminal, all you do is click on this
plus. Opens up a brand new terminal. You
just come down, you select it, hit
enter, and then you're rocking and
rolling. Then we're going to select
Claude to summon him. Now let's begin
the entire process. So hey there, I've
just added two additional skills to the
left hand side. A 3D website builder,
and then I've added a 3D website asset
generator. What I would like you to do
is create two skills included for those
two things. And I'd like to start with a
3D website ass generator. You can tell
what website we're building based on the
information on the left. But I would
like to create for this website a pool
that basically goes from being dirty and
filthy to completely clean. Do this to
build out the gorgeous um animation
files for me. So I can just copy and
paste and make it look epic. Now what
this will do actually is generate for us
three different prompts that we're going
to need to use on whatever image
generation we're using to create this
beautiful animation. So whilst this is
creating the asset, let's go over to
Hicksfield to use this. Now you don't
have to use Hicksfield, but I'm going to
use it here because it's a really easy
way to actually generate some credible
images. So you're going to image
hickfield.ai. Great. You're going to
sign in and or create an account. So
let's get rid of this guy real quick.
Come over and log in. Continue with
Google. Wonderful. And so now we've got
three prompts. Yours will look exactly
like this cuz you've got the code. We've
got the dirty pool. We've got the
crystal clean pool. And then the video
transition. So let's grab the dirty
pool. Click on copy. And guys, you know
I'm a sucker for my confetti, but we
grab that. Now, let's head over to
Hicksfield. Then, guys, you click on
images over here on the left hand side
and click on create an image and you'll
be here. Now, I've done all of the work
for you in terms of what you actually
need because we want a white background.
So, we come in, we're going to drop in
the prompt like so, which is fantastic.
Now, dimensions, make sure that you are
at 16x9. Quality control, we want to be
2K. And then the model is going to be
Nano Banana 2, which is fantastic. And
again, just make sure we got the right
dimensions on there. Make sure the right
quality controls at 2K. And then
literally we want four generations so we
can pick the perfect dirty neglected
pool. Come over and click on generate.
Wonderful. So now we've got some dirty
pools. Oh my gosh, guys. Look at this.
Are you Are you thirsty? You thirsty for
some pools right now? So you can pick
the one that you want to. I always
recommend at this stage spa with it a
little bit. Find one that you like. You
want little bits in there? You want
There was a giraffe in the last video. I
don't know if my edits can pull up right
now that disappeared in the van. So if
you want to add a giraffe in here, we
can make anything happen. So very, very
crazy. Let's pick one that looks really
dirty. Maybe we go for Yeah, let's go
for this one here that's particularly um
pungent and doesn't look very nice.
Click on reference. And all we're going
to do now is pretty much delete this
prompt like so. And get rid of this guy.
And then we come back over to our
document here on the crystal clean pool
one. We're just going to copy it. Then
come straight back over and paste it in.
And one thing you'll notice is that the
outskirts are white. This is so it will
blend perfectly into your website. One
option you have got if you want I want
to throw out there so you're aware of it
is you can go more detailed like this.
Like you see how this one for example
looks really freaking bad. Like look at
that. How terrible that looks. So we can
play around with that if you want to. So
it kind of a little bit more integrated.
But you get the idea. It's essentially
how well do you want it to integrate
into the website? But you can play
around with that and get it so it's
absolutely like really filthy. So you
could for example come down here and
click on reference and we could say
something like um let's just make sure
that it's a full white border and cut
off the stuff at the bottom. And then
you effectively once you've given it
some feedback you get two that you
really like. So I really like this one
here. So, this one is so freaking bad,
man. Is this what the average pool owner
in Texas looks like? Maybe you Texans
can gonna let me know. I'd love to come
out there one day. Maybe live. I think
it'd be cool. And then this is the free
version. Cool. The clean. This is after
Diamond Pool Clean Services. Ruck up.
But this is just what we do. This is how
we roll. That's what kind of experience
we set. What we're going to do now is
download this one here. Let's get this
one downloaded onto the computer. And
then we're also going to go ahead and
download this guy right here. Fantastic.
Then we're going to head over on the
left hand side onto video like so. And
click on create a video. And then all
you're going to do, guys, is have your
start frame. And you're just going to
basically click on that image. So now
we've got our before photo and then
we're going to have afterwards our after
photo of our beautiful pool. Then we're
going to go ahead and grab a prompt from
our AI, which is over here. Nvidia
transition. Just copy this bad boy. Come
back over. And then we're going to feed
that into the model like so. Fantastic.
And then you can specify everything you
want to down here. Quality 5 seconds I
think is going to be fine for this. We
don't need the audio in this instance
cuz it's not really relevant. And then
we want to do multi-shot shouldn't be
okay. It depends like you know you can
play around a little bit. Usually I
found it's quite okay but you can
experiment and then click on generate.
Now as you can see the one from before
this was the van one with the giraffe.
There he is. People say he disappeared.
I actually think he just went into the
van for a little bit of relaxing guys. I
think people were too harsh on our
giraffe. He likes to hang out, chill out
and do what he likes to do. Wonderful.
So now we have the whole image which is
decent. So let's go ahead and hit play
and see what that one looks like. Just
like that. All beautiful Clint. That's
the kind of effect that we have. And of
course you can play around as much as
you want to. You can just say for
example create a beautiful seamless
transition between the two. Make sure
any objects that are exiting do so in a
natural way. Make it a seamless
beautiful transition. You can play
around with it. I encourage you to do a
few of these just to make sure that
you're happy with it. Model cling 3.0 is
fine. You can play around different
models. Of course you can. It's really
up to you how you want to play around
with it. And of course you can up
quality if you want to. It just costs a
few more credits. So we'll try this one
with 1080p. Cool. And so I've got a new
one here. And guys, actually, I think
going up a little bit on quality has
really elevated the feel of this and
things are just getting swept away.
Things are falling down. I think it
looks a little bit better, but play
around with it. Create as many different
things as you want to. And when this is
And so to download it, we're going to
come over here. We're going to come and
grab this guy like so. And just bring it
onto our computer, which is fantastic.
Then we head over to anti-gravity. And
then once we've downloaded, just come
over, grab the file, drop it straight
in. And then we're going to have and yap
to Claude and just give it the following
prompt. Hey there. So I have just
downloaded a file a video and I would
like this to be at the very top of the
website. Now I want you to integrate it
in such a way that as I scroll down
basically it looks like an animation.
You need to change the top of the
website to white and you can use the 3D
website builder for best principles in
terms of how to integrate this animate
this sort of like scroll effect. As I
scroll down the website the pool gets
clean basically. Beautiful. So here we
go. And by the way, if it doesn't work
the first time, just come back and say,
"Hey dude, I want it to be a bit slower,
a bit faster. I've added the best
practices in my skill, but here's
Diamond Dool Services." We scroll down.
What do we see? And look at that. This
could be your pool. Get a free estimate.
How cool is that? That is so sick. And
we come down the website. We've got
everything we had here earlier.
Professional service, maintenance, and
repair, pool care that protects your
investment. And we go all the way down
the website looking really slick, really
decent, and we got everything that we
wanted. Six reasons to trust us. That
basically scroll up thing has
disappeared. We've got the reviews on
Facebook, everything we do, free report
cleaner, and a contact form at the
bottom. And then of course, we just want
to test the mobile optimization cuz
guys, I know we love our tablets. I
don't know who's surfing the web on a
tablet in 2026. If that's you, can you
let me know down in the comments? I
genuinely I want to know. But the point
is, you can see it scales well. Now, the
cool thing about this image is even if
you're like mobile or whatever, you can
still see the pool transforming as you
come down. You can see beautiful. This
pool could be yours. You actually need
the external context on this, which is
why it's great to have an image like
this. So, cool. And obviously you can
change it. You can even do one for a
mobile versus a desktop. All you do is
repeat the same process but make it
square. Or you could make it long long
sort of like a horizontal if you want to
and it'll be the same kind of process.
And all you say to Claude is just change
it when it hits a certain break point
that is reasonable and that'll come down
and then work well for you. And this is
completely mobile optimized guys. This
is a really gorgeous, gorgeous, gorgeous
website that you would be happy to use.
There a few things we can do in terms of
functionality which is decent. And to
fix that we're going to use a UIUX pro
skill. And to do that, you come over to
this website here. And what this effect
is, guys, a lot of people, okay, that
are very big nerds on UIUX. Basically
sat together in a room, I believe, and
they built this incredible thing out
which basically tests it for hundreds of
minute things, accessibility, design,
SEO, you name it, it's in here. So, what
we're going to do now is literally come
over, you're going to copy this code
like so. Click on copy, head back over
to anti-gravity, which will pull up at
the bottom, and then effectively, we're
going to say the following. Hey there,
I'd like you to download the skill and
do a full audit of this website for me.
making sure that it is fully SEO
optimized and is fully accessible based
on all the requirements that are
basically mentioned in this skill.
Install it on the left hand side. And
once that's done, just give me a cool
checklist of everything you've done uh
and all the changes that you've made. As
simple as that. And then drop the URL,
guys. And just like that, it's done 15
critical accessibility takes. It's done
a skip link. It's got navbar sorted out.
It's done so many different things. It's
done eight fixes on SEO, which is
fantastic. It's done various different
improvements on image dimensions, form
and feedback, you know, touch and
interaction. You think about how long it
would take you and I sat down going
through this stuff. This skull's done
all that for us, which I think is
freaking crazy. It's also installed the
skull on the left hand side. I always
recommend that you just run this as an
order on whatever website that you're
building. So now we have a beautiful
website that is SEO optimized, looks
gorgeous, and has a scroll stopping
animation on it. The next problem we
have to solve though is once we give
this to a client, how on earth do they
tell us what they want to change? Maybe
they want to change the copy. How do you
actually solve that? Well, there are
actually three ways. Way number one is
they just pay you to do it and you're on
retainer. That is the best way. I cover
that in my big AI website masterass. The
second route is that you build out a
full CMS where they can do changes. Now,
that's great cuz I have autonomy, but if
they do something that breaks the
website, that can complicate it. And
then there's a third option. There's a
really interesting middle ground. Makes
it easy, but also gives them the ability
to make changes through you. So the way
we do this is we build them a page in
the same style as their website which
you can do with the prompt I'm going to
show you in a second. You can add in
their names. They basically they can
fill everything out like diamond D just
like this. They don't want a design
tweak, a bug issue, new feature, other.
It's a really gorgeous interactive
section. This is so nice. You could even
have this on the website if you wanted
to click on about. They could do
everything. And when that's submitted
that goes through to this on notion
which is client request and this could
just be the thing that you check every
day. Go through what do they want? Do I
want X? Do I want Y? And you can give
this to Claude. You can give this to
anti-gravity and say every day like go
and check it. Whatever changes, approve
it and build a skill that says if it's
just to do with copy, we let that go. If
it's a structural change, you can manage
it. And then you can manage all of your
clients here on the left hand side, all
their requests, get that complete. And
it's a complete it just takes the back
and forth of you and the and the
customer way out of your hands because
it all runs there in the background.
I've also created for you a client
feedback portal setup guide that just
feed this to cla code in the same chat
window. or it doesn't need to be the
same chat window, but just give it to
Claude code and it'll go ahead and
develop for you one of these things. The
only thing you need to do is give it
your notion API key. If you don't know
how to do that, just come on the top
right, come down here to connections,
click on develop integration, and on
develop integration, all you're going to
do is create a new integration. You're
going to give it a name and you're going
to grab an API key. Then once you give
that API key to claude code, you can
effectively connect it. And you just
give it a prompt just by copying this
whole thing I dealt for you here and
you'll be ready to connect it and have
the whole system ready to rock and roll.
Now, a beautiful website is one thing,
but actually building it with more
detail and hosting it is something
completely different.